ابو خليل مصاب بالفشل الكلوي
تتسارع نبضات قلبه
ويساوره القلق من ان تكون هذه المره
الاخيره التي يستطيع فيها استخدام جهاز
غسل الكلى في اكبر مستشفيات قطاع غزه
فهذه الاجهزه مهدده بالتوقف نتيجه نقص
المستلزمات الطبيه ما يهدد حياه ابو خليل
ومئات المرضى في قطاع غزه فاي دوله في اي
عالم
اما احنا لا مش مبطلنا ولا مفره شغله
تشتد تداعيه الازمه الصحيه مع استمرار
السلطات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في منع ادخال
ادويه ومستلزمات طبيه ضروريه لمرضى الفشل
الكلوي والاورام هناك رصيد من الادويه صفر
لا يوجد اي ادويه وهناك بعض الادويه
رصيدها 50% وهناك 70% فالازمه كبيره يعني
مستفحله صراحه منذ فتره
ادخال الادويه ومستلزمات الاجهزه الطبيه
الى قطاع غزه يحتاج الى تنسيق من جانب
مؤسسات دوليه مع الاحتلال الاسرائيلي قد
يمتد عده اشهر وقد يرفض الاحتلال السماح
بادخالها المسؤول اساس هو سلطات الاحتلال
التي تحاصر غزه التي تدفع دائما غزه على
سفير الكارثه هي بوعي هي تضع غزه على شفي
الكارثه بعد الاحتلال ياتي مقدمي الخدمات
وزاره الصحه سواء في غزه او في رام الله
عليها واجب ان تعطي اولويه لهذا النوع من
الامراض لهذه الانواع من المستلزمات
والادويه لانها تحدد حياه الانسان
وبهذا تكون الاوضاع الصحيه والانسانيه
رهينه استمرار الحصار الاسرائيلي على قطاع
غزه حياه مئات المرضى في قطاع غزه مهدده
بشكل جدي كما يشخص ذلك الاطباء فبينهم
مرضى الفشل الكلوي والاورام الذين يحتاجون
الى ادويه حيويه بعضها غير متوفر فلا هم
يستطيعون تلقي العلاج خارج القطاع ولا تلك
الادويه تصل اليهم الوضع ذاته مستمر انه
الحصار الاسرائيلي هشام زقوت الجزيره غزه
فلسطين